a tree in a Florida swamp Egret chicks
compete for food and attention from mob
down below hungry Gators gather where
there are wobbly chicks there's the
promise of mana falling from heaven the
Egret seen as oblivious to the Gators as
the Gators seem obsessed with the
egrants it looks like a standard until a
Darwinian melodrama plays itself out in
a nest about mccobb barely describes
this Egret version of Lord of the Flies
in a bid for survival to stronger chicks
mall a weaker sibling with the runt out
of the way there will be more food for
the other two down below the alligators
watch this grizzly patch and eagerly
the bigger sibling stabbed and
bludgeoned a little one until he
succumbs then the Gators below make like
NBA centers leaping for a rebound at
playoff time
it may seem mean to humans but it truly
is survival of the fittest